who doesn't enjoy taking everyone's
clothes off exploring wet caves and
power fisting yep fallout 4 has captured
the hearts and minds of the nation so
much so that they don't even go in on
pornhub anymore so grab your helmet and
your fat man and get ready for a game
spot news update on November the 10th
the day that Bethesda's long-awaited
role-playing game Fallout 4 finally
arrived on consoles and PC traffic on
pornhub fell by as much as 10 percent
the site announced this week pornhub
released this chart showing the traffic
was actually up five percent among
gamers in the early morning hours of 3
to 4 a.m. which the site said was
probably when fallout 4 was installing
but starting at around five a.m. pornhub
traffic dropped diving as much as ten
percent from seven a.m. to 12noon in the
afternoon traffic returned to normal but
after 6pm it dropped again when we
assumed that nine to five workers
arrived home and fired up their games
pornhub set in their safer work blog
post after midnight it seems like
everyone finally took a break and
traffic jump as high as fifteen percent
above daily norms to further charts
revealed percent change statistics for
pornhub visitors based on their gaming
genre preferences as you can see sports
game fans saw the biggest drop off
compared to an average day minus
thirteen point seven percent followed by
action game fans at minus seven point
seven percent and adventure and strategy
game fans minus seven point two percent
interestingly RPG fans are lower on the
list falling by just three point six
percent so uh have you been playing
fallout 4 instead of the things you'd
normally do you don't have to let us
know in the comments really just tell us
who your favorite companion is instead
I'm gate you can find me on Twitter at
how not to draw and thanks for watching
if I may say ego of the night